hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to getting over it with
Bennet fadi now this is the destroy my
channel challenge it's one of those
things that I just came up with because
I'm an idiot but here's the deal if if
if if if if if I curse any curse word
any curse word at all anything swear
word doesn't matter if I curse in this
playthrough you have to unsubscribe from
my channel that is the guarantee if I
curse you unsubscribe but on the
flipside if I make forward progress you
subscribe I don't even care if it's a
subscription back it's you who if I
curse you unsubscribe for my channel but
if I make forward progress you have to
subscribe and if you're already
subscribed then wait until I curse and
then re subscribe okay alright no I'm
fine I'm fine
no no this is how it's gonna work I all
you need to agree with me on this one
trust me I know what I'm doing maybe
probably not but I'm in a good place
right here no no no no this is the only
way it's gonna work you gotta believe me
you gotta believe me
if the stakes are gonna be high enough
to motivate me to get through this game
I have to do it with calmness in my soul
and this is how it's gonna work that's
why it's called the destroy my channel
challenge
so if you guys are ready we're gonna do
this but in before people are just
saying I'm trying to get out of 22 nudes
tasteful nudes at 20 million subscribers
doesn't matter this is the stakes right
here if
make forward progress then I'm gonna get
like closer to the tasteful nudes but
this is it
now I haven't cursed yet but if I curse
at all you must subscribe okay all right
I am the comest I've ever been in my
life nothing could possibly nothing
could possibly get in my way yes like
the calmest butterfly making forward
[Laughter]
problems on that there Mouse okay all
right like the gentlest but cheerfully
all right okay all right everything's
fine everything is fine because I you
you you you - Philippe in the wind
earth circle I've made forward progress
guys this is officially forward progress
okay so if you're just joining if you're
just joining here's the deal this is
called to destroy my channel challenge
I haven't cursed yet but here's the
stakes if I curse you have to
unsubscribe for my channel that's the
deal but if I make forward progress you
subscribe so I can lose subscribers on
cursing but I can gain them back with
forward progress so it's rewarding my
own success yeah oh yeah I don't think I
can grab on to this can i Yee this would
be a terrible idea
[Music]
[Music]
alright okay I just got a make I don't
know but I have a funky feeling monkey
screams don't count as curse monkey
screams ain't no curse okay right
Oh ah that's a slippery Rock duty fruity
okay
we're fine okay
ah all right I don't I don't know how to
progress from here I just don't know if
I don't know how I don't know how to
progress from here I don't know I don't
know how to do it I don't know how to do
it ah maybe no that'd be a bad idea okay
I haven't sworn yet I haven't sworn I
haven't sworn haven't sworn swear on me
mum anger is fine anger is perfectly
fine it's just swearing that will
destroy my oh yeah by the end of the
Simone I'm gonna have negative
subscribers who okay I think I have to
leap for it
that's it seems like the only conclusion
here I'm pretty sure that I have to leap
for it but I'm not a hundred percent on
that one
I'm just guesstimating I almost made it
I almost made it I almost made it I
almost made it
don't leap why wouldn't I leap I have to
leap there's no other way right maybe
there's another way
okay I'm gonna try something here I
wonder why I wonder nah there's no way
now yeah there's no way I can set myself
on that so I just gonna get into the I
just got to get into this corner here
that's all I want right now right in
that corner yeah okay that way okay so
maybe maybe there is a way to nuzzle in
here if I'm just so no there's no way
there's no way that ain't happening
that is Nate happenin having cursed yet
okay I I almost had it before so I just
got to do that again I can nuzzle up to
here
but this is as nozzoli as it's gonna get
for me damn it
yeah that's his nozzle as it's gonna get
so any forward progress has to be made
from here okay if you're just joining me
once again I will reiterate the rules
because I have a funny feeling that it
might apply at this point oh no monkey
screams don't count so it's called the
destroy my channel challenge because if
I curse if I curse and every one of you
is agreeing to this by participating in
the stream if I curse you have to
unsubscribe for my channel now I haven't
cursed yet but if I make this jump that
counts as forward progress and then you
have to subscribe that's the deal that
we're all making here understood okay so
I stand to lose everything
great yes that words a bad word you're
not gonna trick me by making me say
words by reading chat because even that
would count even if I'm reading it in
chat okay so prime for launch here we go
alright take 2 no potato aardvark
No
okay it's fine it's fine
I didn't say anything I didn't I didn't
curse that was a lovely adventure I'm
happy that happened I'm happy I'm very
happy whoa hello hi friend hi friendly
friend friendly friend who's friendly to
me friendly friendly friend friend
friend friend friend friend friend
friend get on the gosh-darn ledge I said
gosh darn I didn't say anything those
gosh darn whoa whoa whoa okay I'm
getting better at that
ain't that a wonderful thing whoa whoa
whoa counter what this whoa whoa that is
a fun adventure all right
fun fun fun fun fun fun fun fun fun fun
fun fun fun fun
Savva kado sushi me hop BA okay Batman
Batman Batman spider-man Batman pardon
me
Batman Piderman Batman Piderman
Batman tider man whoa hey that's
adventurous let's just tickle fate here
okay all right uh
Skoosh and Skoosh okay we're back
ah that's that's the good stuff okay all
right
okay all right okay all right
okay
oh no this was a mistake this was a
mistake this was a mistake
[Music]
I I my mouse died whoa my mouse died
well that's a problem my mouse finally
kicked the bucket I don't know what to
do about this situation
ah I'll get another one
and I'm not cursing not at all
[Music]
tennis football americano I haven't
destroyed my channel yet I haven't said
a single curse word
don't don't don't don't do nothing don't
do nothing okay don't do nothing don't
do nothing okay all right we're back
online we're back online I'm not okay
I'm not okay I'm not okay I'm not okay
mmm slow and steady slow and steady wins
the race
slow and steady okay that's lovely the
way that that's now set up okay
all right slow and steady no need to be
fancy feet about this no need to be
fancy feast about this is my favorite Oh
criminy sagol I don't even think that's
a word but it's not a curse word bum
poopy patootie that's not a curse word
uh-uh
I don't even know why that happened
why why do oh why did that happen that
shouldn't have happened that shouldn't
have happened
there was no whoa hey whoa god damn it
god damn you Oh No
ah how did I follow how do I follow I
wasn't big invented well there goes my
subscriptions oh no oh no oh no I said
hack hack hack oh gosh golly
Michelangelo oh gee yep
that's the price that's why it's called
that's why it's called to destroy my
channel challenge that's why it's called
this you guys better be true to your
word hey I don't want you taking pity on
me I cursed I curse you better
unsubscribe that is how this game works
if I make forward progress I'll get him
back but that's how this game works okay
this is a game that destroys lives and
it's destroying mine so I just wanted to
prove it and show that the developer
never should have made this game cuz
it's Garbo right you guys be true to me
I'll be true to you I don't want to know
I don't want to know I don't want to
none I said it I said it I said it
that's true and it's just the way it is
oh it's the way it is so be true I gotta
get back boy hey I'm a man of my word
you better you better beat you I'm a man
of my word I'm a man of my word are you
gonna are you gonna lie to me we all
agreed going into this stream we all
agreed we all agreed that's how it was
gonna be and if you go back on your word
then I am ashamed I'm ashamed you all
have an opportunity to get it back I
will I promise
oh come on yeah there you go yeah
don't be sorry if you did it it's how it
works its name in this game whoa whoa
hey whoa hey whoa hey whoa hey whoa boy
this guy is very active today okay there
we are
all right skadoodle doodle my noodle
come on yeah I'm getting better at it
see I am better at the control
it's just when I have to be very
cautious and careful that I start to get
nervous and I question my abilities as a
as a hammer swinger also this this path
here I'm not sure how you do it because
I'm not sure how to get the most
strength of your swing Swan cuz I've
tried I've tried a few times huh and
it's like I can't get enough lift out of
it so I gotta go okay that didn't count
as forward progress either let's say I
have to get back to where at least I was
before people start subscribing again
but to be perfectly honest I should have
to get past that point before people
start subscribing again that's the only
way that's the only way you guys you
guys be true to me I'll be true to you
whenever I led you astray ba boom ba
home ba Oh Betty do you will be good to
me and I'll be good to you please
someone please I want someone to please
someone start streaming a live feed of
my subscription count please do that
numerous people just have people posting
live subscription like on social blade
you can see the actual live numbers I
just want to see like just mess with
everyone's metrics for a full day whoa
okay that's an option whoa
hahaha the swing swung is strong in me
alright
come on pull pull pull pull
there we go whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa jeezum x' see
that's what I don't get it can go a mil
what Oh
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
it can go a million miles an hour if you
can go a million miles an hour in the
direction that I don't want it to go for
some reason oh really oh no no no no no
no no no no no no no sass Sassafrass uh
soup well come on pull ah for some
reason for some reason my ability to
pull in isn't working and I don't know
why like whoa whoa whoa Wow oh geez
Jesus Jesus criminy Christmas huh I just
want to pull in okay whoa whoa whoa it's
really twitchy right now I'd like to
think that it's randomly generated
attitudes about this guy you know he's
just whoa he just gets real emotional
like me like me like me like me okay
[Music]
come on no whoa wait whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa easy up there easy up there Sally
sue come on you nope go go go
Gus gum gum grandma the worst curse word
there is grandma there we go come on
whoa push why put why are you pushing
off of that thing why see whoa whoa whoa
whoa easy there see I was not moving my
mouse all that much in
in that encounter and yet I was going
ten million miles an hour as like the
mouse is trying to compensate oh whoa
trying to compensate for where it thinks
it should be yeah it can do that
sometimes and said whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa oh whoa
I guess we're climbing like this then
huh whoa
nope okay well that was a lot of
movement for a lot of nothing huh whoa
okay okay ha
whoa see ah seasons just there we go all
right good enough man it loves to be
funky funky fresh is the name of this
game whoo-hoo everyone calm down calm
down calm down calm calm calm as the
summer breeze calm as grandma's feet
whoa see you're being a little antsy
pants II and I don't appreciate it
antsy pants II whoa
that was almost too much okay all right
let's gently
there we go there we go
whoo I'll take it here we go oh those
mistake
oh come on the push the push the push
it's the push why why does it bounce
like that I don't understand every time
it just bounce whoa it just bounces like
that oh my goodness gravy ah well see ah
why does it go down I don't want you to
go whoa okay we're climbing now
apparently now now is the time to climb
goodness gravy oh my god God is not a
curse word God is not a curse word
what
Oh see
Oh little antsy little antsy a little
antsy
little antsy but calm as the summer
breeze oh oh hey pop-tarts whoo hey Wow
okay that's it oh no I'm going here now
apparently whoa whoa no ants in my pants
there may be on sin this man's caldron
Adrian okay
[Music]
it sure does love to just slide off at
any Willie which away okay all right now
the question of the day that I always
seem to have is can I fit in this little
crack and what would it take to be able
to do that
[Music]
number five Mambo number 5 huh
Randall
[Music]
[Music]
oh why why why why Wimbledon Wimbledon
Wimbledon fun fun fun fun fun I'm having
fun
video games it's like it's trying to
send me down I don't understand it's
trying to send me down it's like so
trying to send me down you guys see them
it's doing it it's doing it's trying
it's working against me are you seeing
this are you seeing this oh why why why
why why why why why why why
fun fun fun fun fun fun fun fun fun fun
fun fun fun fun fun fun fun fun fun fun
fun fun fun this game is fun fun fun
games are fun fun fun fun fun fun fun
fun No
fun fun fun fun fun fun fun fun fun fun
fun fun fun fun fun fun fun fun I'm
having fun fun fun fun fun fun it's fun
it's fun it's fun it's fun fun no it's
fun it's fun guys it's fun fun
[Music]
fun
[Music]
fun one Fun Fun Fun Fun Fun Fun Fun Fun
Fun Fun Fun Fun Fun Fun Fun Fun Fun Fun
Fun Fun Fun Fun Fun Fun Fun Fun Fun Fun
Fun Fun Fun know it's so much fun I'm
having the time of my life see that one
that shortcut it's so hard I don't
understand how you do it reliably I've
done it like once before but never high
enough it's never enough god I don't I
don't know it's not like I'm moving my
mouse slow either it's it's something
else - it's like something about the
arrow see I can launch myself a million
miles in the wrong door in the wrong
direction just by the nature of the way
this game works but when it comes down
to the wire really
yeah that ain't happening I use
centripetal force
oh really yeah really centripetal force
sure yeah let's go with that one
Oh mmm lovely lovely time that I uh
[Music]
there we go whoa whoa how'd it loss it
loss it but have it okay nope maybe baby
baby baby baby baby baby baby baby baby
fun fun fun fun super duper fun super
fun super fun super fun
i-i-i-i super fun super fun super fun
super fun super fun super fun super fun
super fun super fun
soo super fun super fun very fun fair
fair also fair this game is fun and fair
this game is fun and his fair and his
fair fun for the whole family to enjoy
fair fun that was fair
Wow yeah this is where I wanted to be
okay
I can't even get in position anymore I
love that ah I wish you would stop I
wish you would stop I wish upon every
star it's impossible there's no way it's
impossible it's impossible it's
impossible it's impossible it's
impossible there is no way to do that
anyone who does do that is a cheater is
cheating just because I mean why would
they cheat this game is so fun by itself
the experience doesn't need to go ruined
by cheating that is the opposite of what
needs to happen see I'm not I didn't do
any of that I didn't do any of that that
was just the game deciding to go a
million miles an hour
nope nope you're gonna go up whether or
not you like it you're gonna go up yeah
yep yep yep there we go no see that was
down oh hey right that's a new direction
that you could go that's a new thing
that could happen I'm so happy about
that thing that happening I'm so happy
cuz I might be so much fun in this super
awesome game or don't grab on anything
oh okay all right new surprises new
surprises you were grabbed on how did
you do nothing how did you do nothing
how did you do nothing how did you do
nothing
ha all right
that's a thing that happened okay
apparently we are in the world where we
don't actually grab on to things and
don't wow that was cool okay
no no no no no the answer is no no
No
fun fun very fun very fun very fun very
fun
ooh Genghis Khan Abraham Lincoln okay oh
why didn't you do anything there what
the heck the hacking hack uh why why why
do you behave the way you do I don't
understand you I just try to understand
sometimes that's all I tried to do and
and the best I get is just a world of
pain ooh see I didn't I'm not didn't do
that didn't do that did not do that
launched upwards didn't do that not me
my mouse was not moving hate that that's
my least favorite thing about this fun
game this fun fantastic fun game this
fun fun fun fun game all right we made
it back I'm having so much fun I'm
having so much fun I'm screaming I'm
screaming fine fine it's so fine
I didn't curse
fun funfun funfunfunfun funfun funfun
funfunfunfun funfun
[Music]
by the way I just invented an anger move
I call it the rage split jump that's
what I call that that is what that is
you know how you just get so angry you
need to express your emotions through
like interpretive dance that's what I do
I'm just a big old raging dancer
[Music]
nope no see up-up-up is the way you're
supposed to go not down not down not
down think wow okay did you see that cuz
I sure didn't
Oh up Oh with - up wow wow just wow all
I have to say about that as well whoa
okay I'm must be in a Twilight Zone
because I am doing things that the game
is do I'm not the game is not doing what
I'm doing ah no please I'm begging you I
got through this so easily before see
you you think you guys might be thinking
like oh you don't need to move as fast I
swear I swear I'm not moving as fast
remember I had to switch Mouse's I had
to switch my losses so suddenly this
mouse bit more sensitive bit more
provocative I'd say hey okay well
pushing off is an option
Wow Wow oh whoa that was rocket speed
downwards rocket speed how does it do
that I just don't get it
no see what hmm it's I'm gonna just do
this
don't oh yeah wait yeah okay alright
just gonna turn that down a smidge cuz I
am getting some effects here Wow okay no
please please please I'm begging you I'm
begging you please please please oh
what
No
options options options this is things
that can happen apparently see I don't
get that snap to it like oh oh please
please I don't get the snapback I know
what it is now but it's still it makes
no sense for a control it makes no sense
why would it be that way okay all right
okay all right who's stuck in the toilet
again nope don't want that that's
happened to me before and I didn't like
it that much
Hey okay that's cool maybe I just need
to stop raging against it and start
going with the flow
Wow see I didn't do that didn't do that
didn't do had nothing to do with that I
had nothing to do with that oh wow wow
wow wow
but anyway when I need to do is I need
to start accounting for that and just
being like it's gonna be like that all
the time except it's not accept no no no
no no no no where am I
I don't
there's no way to get back I could try
to get on that lamp but I don't I don't
think I would serve my
fun remember guys this games fun this
game is super fun and I still have not
cursed again Wow okay
oh okay all right Kirsten Stewart
ah grab see it didn't do the horrible
swing there but it did Oh a swing there
which is fascinating it did a swing like
that's what I just don't get it does it
am I just moving my mouse wrong because
as soon as I'm done like as soon as I'm
done I don't move my mouse anymore like
I I'm it works many times whereas just
like once I'm done with the movement I
don't move my mouse unless I'm trying to
chain up a move but maybe there you go
again being super super super speedy on
what you're doing why why why are you so
speedy I don't understand I am not
moving my mouse that much at all stay
right there
get farther up on it Wow what why oh my
goodness gracious oh my goodness
gracious oh my goodness gracious okay
okay we made it back we made it back
okay calm and collected there we go
there we go everyone calm and collected
OOP bouncy bouncy bouncy bouncy bouncy
boy
bouncy boy
Oh
Oh
Oh
what
Wow do I really slide off of that one
Oh
what
I am silent because if I open my mouth
I'm going to lose my entire channel in
the string of curse words that I will
omit so bear with me as I let the rage
subside which is an I impossibility in
the face of this game
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
oh why I'm not going [ __ ] you guys
are seeing me I'm not doing anything
differently I'm approaching this as
calmly as I can this fun fun game this
fun fun game okay all right all right
okay all right okay
happy thoughts are flowing through my
brain happy happy thoughts happy
thoughts at how happy I am and how happy
I will be once I get past this one point
in the game if I could just only get
there which I will cuz I believe in
myself that's what I do
Oh
[Music]
what
I will be so happy when I finally
finally get past this one part which is
gonna happen cuz I believe in myself I
believe in myself I do I really truly
honestly do I do what I do I really do I
really do believe in myself I believe in
myself because I am a winner I'm a
winner I'm a winner who wins it winning
I'm a winner I'm just a happy whoa what
was that maneuver I'm just a winner
I'm just happy oh yeah oh that feels
good oh that feels good oh let the
dopamine flow through oh okay
now this is gonna be the calmest
gentlest ascent you ever did see because
I am the the man with the plan
okay
now you tell me you tell me right now
and don't lie to me what's the best way
to get past this one point what is the
best way to get past this point is it to
launch myself which I don't know if I
can reach or is it to try and climb up
this part here as sheer as that is as
sheer as that is as sheer as that is is
it better to do that than to try to jump
launch yourself okay all right that's
what I thought that's what I thought
that's what I thought
that's what I thought okay use momentum
so I've got myself right here and I'm
just gonna sew right along this lovely
path here
whoa hey whoa whoa okay that's that's
fun
Oh
what
I have to fast launch no way really if
only I knew how to do that if only there
was a way
[Music]
No
whoa
[Music]
[Music]
okay all right
okay
oh why would you do that why would you
scare me you scared me you scared me you
scared me you scared me you scared me
ah dopamine dopamine rush again do not
launch okay do not launch you know what
I'm gonna try that don't launching route
because that's what I think is a good
idea
is
know what why push why why did it push
why did it push why did it push why did
it push gosh golly jiminy Christmas life
why would you do that why would you do
that other than to betray me
Bennett fadi you are the one who is
betraying me bang at 40 I will find you
I will find you no slippery slippery
like like a Dalmatian and Lube slippery
like the Knights Oh clean film losing
sanity quickly aren't I gentlemen and
why would you do something of that
caliber rude is grab and now we will get
to the part where we launch
okay we have slipped in like butter on a
knife mmm delicious
well what I will air whoa hey whoa now
you don't need to be so shaggy
mister you just need to be classy mm-hmm
using Jannetty is part of YouTube it's
part of it wow that was quite a grip on
you mister man why why I ask again
to nobody
what bride why why why why why why why
I'm gonna pass out
oh boy
ah I live I live
ah man man
someone said turn off mouse cursor I
don't even know that's not gonna help is
it
[Music]
what
what
No
No
what
all right
okay okay I don't know if that helped at
all I don't actually think it helped it
all but psychologically speaking maybe
it did I don't know I could use a lot of
psychological help in this game anything
to make me believe that I have a chance
okay please I just need to get back to
where I was so not too strong
[Music]
ooh
[Music]
whoo-hoo
it died yep that broke so now I don't
have a chair that's nice I got a backup
come here surely you thought you were
out of woods Cheerilee fun fun fun
chairs dead now turn down mouse
sensitivity then I just got to relearn
it all over again
how about 0 no oh yeah 0 that's the good
that is the good stuff
why is that more sensitive
I shouldn't be that sensitive anyway oh
that is slow going whoo
now that is very different who that is
oh that is raucously different launch a
but I still launched good that's nice
what
well that's now that's just weird
because the sensitivity is down yes but
the actions of launching are just as
good now doesn't that tell a story about
this game that was different
Oh weird very strange very strange I
don't hate it even that I can still do
that pretty quickly all right
oh hey friend okay
all right okay
whoa hey won't help me if I do things
like that
okay whoa whoops not what I meant
oh no we don't oh okay all right
bouquet bouquet bouquet
okay Oh bouquet bouquet bouquet bouquet
bouquet there's hope this just the
tiniest bit of hope
not a lot mind you not a lot of hope but
tiny bit bouquet
yeah cuz the launches are still snappy
but the control is much better much
better oh well that's a delightful now I
don't know if I'm gonna be able to get
this now because my calibration is all
off but ok ok ok all right
okay so the answer is I have to launch
myself I do I'm pretty sure I do
I almost had it a few times and I'm
probably gonna fall anyway like that's
just my lot in life so might as well go
out with the best possible effort I can
right yeah let me get a bit of a steeper
launch for that just just cuz I don't
want the head of the axe catching on
anything or rather my angle be better
okay here we go whoa hello alright but
I'm not as infuriated as that because
that was 100% my fault
I'm never mad at a game oh wow hey if
it's my fault but this new sensitivity
this is way better this is way better
this is way better like I am NOT gonna
lie this is way better it feels more
consistent feels like I actually have
control like I actually am doing the
things that I want to do instead of the
game deciding to do something for me now
the game still has moments where it's
like I'm gonna bounce here like right
there but you know at least I can know
that my [ __ ] flailing afterward
afterwards is gonna do less to destroy
me whoa yeah well alright then still
gotta get used to it this is a it's a
learning curve of itself but overall
whoa still better than what I was
dealing with yeah I just don't think I
don't think I launched with enough woo
hoo just yeah I don't think I launched
woo
alright well back here launch with
enough space cuz I tried to launch with
whoa ah see low sensitivity I didn't I'm
ooh ha see God that was my fault that
was 100% my fault because I did
swing enough cuz I'm still getting used
to the sensitivity level whoa whoa whoa
I will change my mind if you send me
back to the beginning I will chew up I
would oh my god I have to relearn this
God that's the bad thing about changing
your sensitivity you have to relearn
rope whoa you have to relearn exactly
how much of one Mouse movement does what
see ya Oh No ya see that wasn't that was
my fault again cuz but at least I'm
feeling like it's my fault
I'd rather have the feeling that I'm
doing this than the game boning me over
which the game was oh really okay that's
the game boning me over come on
Oh see I can't oh the new sensitivity ah
come on nope
not that much okay I got to relearn
everything now okay there we go there
okay got that all right okay everybody
hold on to your pants everybody hold on
to your chairs I'm coming into town you
know people are gonna quote my chair
destroying habit started when I was back
in 2012 when I use Joe oh whoa hey wow
wow
God okay I hate it I hate it I hate it
ah god it's like I don't know how much
to use Oh Frick it's almost too low
you know I think it is I think it's
mouse acceleration Mouse acceleration is
my least favorite thing in computers I
always turned it off I think this has
mouse acceleration turned on which is
super inconvenient whoa new note the
bounce that bounce goopy goopy goopy in
my pants II win see win see
gooshie goopy ah why did I have to
change things
no oh all right well that's I meant to
do that
[Music]
try trackpad tuning what does that mean
why hate that I hate wait ah but wait is
that one to one it's one to one it's one
to one
it's one to one it's one to one whoa
whoa it's one to one
oh wait is that
am I am i full am I so away it is that's
one to one
I don't know if I like it but that's
what I was talking about that that bunk
whoa hey I don't know if I'm gonna like
this ooh yeah don't like that don't like
that no no no don't like this I hate
this oh maybe I don't know it's hard to
tell it's like it's like each time I
change something I have to relearn it
whoa
maybe whoa I guess oh whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
why whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa hate it
hate it
Oh hate it hate it hate it hate it I
hate that hate that hate that hate that
hate that hate that okay turning this up
a bit
just a bit good god worst thing ever
life is terrible in the neighborhood
life is terrible in the neighborhood I
hate life life hates me we hate life
life is hate full of hate it's full of
hate but we all hate each other equally
whoa
we all hate each other equally which
what makes us makes us able to live as a
society oh boy I don't like this at all
no I don't like this at all
no I don't like this at all
no I don't like this at all okay
[Music]
relearning everything is crap okay you
know what
yeah methinks methinks if if it ain't
broke which it was but if it ain't that
broke don't fix it too much okay I will
make forward progress I have to I have
to there is no other way
oh no no no go up up jeez ohms
golly gosh miss oh my golly gosh miss oh
my golly gosh miss I know you guys are
sick of seeing the same thing over and
over and over again I know this you if
you're oh come on if you're sick of it
imagine how I feel imagine how I feel
just imagine
whoa why whoa whoa whoa whoa easy there
easy easy easy easy no easy easy easy
easy
Oh easy gentle bear gentle Bear gentle
bustling bear gentle Bear gentle Bear
gentle Bear gentle be gentle bear gentle
bear gentle gentle gentle bear gentle
gentle gentle very gentle gentle gentle
soft baby hush baby soft baby hush baby
soft baby hush baby soft baby hush baby
okay soft baby hush baby soft baby hush
baby soft baby hush baby okay whoa not
there soft baby hush baby
we few kits just stop tilting no oh very
gentle but not that gentle soft baby
hush baby soft baby hush baby soft baby
hush baby
it's off baby hush baby
I really don't think I can leap that
high like I've made some leaps in my
life I think the only way to do it is to
swing like do a swing launch whoa hey
easy there but even then it's like
that's a big jump it's just like this is
is a hefty jump yeah ooh yeah I just
don't have the confidence to do it that
way do not jump launch you guys you guys
just you guys just have no idea what to
do and it's just nothing okay come on
try something I don't think it's enough
but can i hey no there's no way you
can't say oh hey yeah you can't set
yourself on that
but maybe I could launch myself if I
launched myself up there I might
all right I'm gonna take it slow
Oh forward progress yes forward progress
yes yes yes the counts that's a place
I've never been before
subscribe yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes subscribe
subscribe subscribe yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah that was the deal I was true
to my word no you be true to your word
that was the deal
I curse you unsubscribe I made progress
you subscribe yeah yeah yes yes all
right here we go okay I think I can just
reach this right yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah baby oh yeah baby oh yeah baby
oh yeah baby oh yeah baby oh yeah baby
careful baby oh hush baby careful baby
Oh easy baby easy baby oh that's a
slanty baby but you just set off forward
progress forward progress forward
progress oh yeah oh oh it feels good oh
that's it that's a lot of dopamine
[Music]
okay here we go here we go here we go go
launch and then grab yes yes oh look at
the thumbs up look at the thumbs up
oh it knows it knows it knows oh it
knows it knows how good I'm doing the
game knows oh the game knows ooh oh my
word I'll bring it in I'll bring it in
I'll bring it in yes
okay
okay
alright okay didn't curse
I usually curse jump-scares but I didn't
get me
alright this is gonna be a doozy I don't
know if I'm this is where I could easily
slide off that's such a tiny hold here
we go all right you know what I'm gonna
try to take it as gentle as I can just
like I just did cuz if I can just let my
hammer like slide along it instead of
pushing I'll reduce the risk of me you
know pushing off oh just like that okay
cool cool
whoo this is precarious okay satting
down coming in for a landing
Hey oh ho all right we got okay tippy
top E tippy top E ah oh this looks like
good oh this looks like good oh this
looks like good it feels like my closer
now composer and climber designer and
use it you could have refused but you
didn't it was something in you that was
hidden tries to continue Oh progress
that's so progress I haven't heard the
narrator's voice in ages cuz he left me
alone cuz I was in such pain oh my
goodness gracious
Oh narrator oh I missed you
not really but Bennett Bennett 4d I know
I've threatened your life many times oh
good news but at least I got like a
checkpoint at least I don't think I can
fail like super hard here because I've
made good progress right can i oh that
is a that's a tight squeeze
oh yeah that's a slippery squeeze okay I
just got a launch up so let me get in
position here this should be good oh how
am I gonna be able to get that angle oh
yeah that's whoa yeah maybe that is the
best way and let me try this
ha oh good thing I've got a safety
like being safe oh yeah everyone knows
that about me
markiplier likes it safe in all things
you know I'm not gonna continue that
train of thought I just do that ok here
we go one two three ah so slippery
ok I do it more ah ah so close okay I
almost got it Oh stupid monkey face ah I
cursed at cursed I cursed I cursed I
cursed unsubscribe I cursed unsubscribe
unsubscribe unsubscribe that's the deal
that's the deal I cursed I'd subscribe
ah okay but if I make it up here then
I'm fine
then Yuri subscribe right come on
subscribe yeah yeah subscribe I made it
I made forward progress Oh what in the
heck is this what
oh no no no no no where does this pit
lead no no
Oh No
no no okay all right I thought that was
gonna be doom oh oh okay all right I was
so scared I was so scared oh I was so
scared I was so scared I was so scared
okay ah the bounce the bounce the bounce
the bounce the bounce the bounce whoo
that bounce though that bounced oh yeah
I had oh hey hey easy there easy there
easy what is that up there it's a branch
oh boy okay okay oh whoa whoa easy there
easy there easy there easy there man
is it doozy ah come on come on come on
come on come on yes yes yes yes forward
progress forward progress oh yes yes it
feels good it feels good yes yes if you
were holding out on the last curse to
subscribe this this is pretty
definitively forward progress at this
juncture oh yes oh yes oh yes okay where
am I headed
okay was with that okay so I need to I
got to go straight up and then okay I
was straight up not clip that grab yeah
just like that
okay is there like to pass here is this
just this just edit means a lot to me
that you've come this far
endured this much every wisecrack every
insensitivity yeah every setback you've
forgiven me is in English if I have not
me I've not forgiven you add a halt I
have not even remotely forgiven you not
that is not what's happening here
forgiveness is not in my nature sir mr.
foggy okay well I'm here now okay
at least that's not deathly at least
that is not deathly that is fine I am
okay with that I am okay with that
okay yeah Oh
Shoom okay this is gonna be this is
gonna be impossible but at least I don't
have the threat of annihilation set
before me now I know that this is just
setting the stage for future
annihilation but you know that's that's
something I'll deal with on another day
right now I just got to bask in the
glory of how I've actually managed to
succeed which is amazing and I'm not a
hundred percent sure how oh okay whoo
hey let's just let's set down to whoo
hey whoa let's sit down short jump Oh
all right on it right on it oh wait this
is getting dangerous if I miss oh geez
oh geez if I'm it oh if I miss it oh
okay I don't think I will
I don't think I'll miss it don't there's
really no way that I could miss this
right just sit down yeah I could get
this cuz we're oh there's more okay
we've officially reached scary territory
Oh No okay if I
okay good thing I didn't
spam anything we have the same taste you
and I it's not ambition its ambitions
opposite an obdurate mission to taste
defeat
you'll feel bad if you win so I put this
snake in for you
[Music]
uh you know I really really really want
to ride that snake I'm not gonna lie
I've never wanted to ride a snake more
in my life than I do right now but I am
gonna take the wise choice because I
have bled too much and I have a funny
feeling that's gonna send me pretty far
back if not all the way I'm not gonna do
that all right
oh this is this is gonna be a pain in
the rumpus ha oh oh oh no it's gonna
make me right if if I somehow fall and
ride that snake I am going to be so mad
I'm gonna be the most mad I've ever been
in my life if I somehow fall and have to
accidentally woo this bucket is gonna be
the death of me
really I had that bucket I had that
bucket by the short hairs okay there we
go
ooh do not ride that's new do not ride
that I don't like this at all
uh I'm gonna try to set on the bucket
but I don't even know it if I set on the
bucket am I even gonna be able to launch
off the bucket do I have to like swing
the bucket oh oh no I don't believe that
this is a good thing for me oh no I
don't like you at all
nope don't like that okay if I fall I
need to do anything but put my hammer to
the left if I put Miami to the left it
could catch the snake and that's bad I'm
pretty sure I have to swing swung with
this I'm almost 100% positive that's why
this bucket is on a rope I'm so scared
I've never been more scared in my life
I'm so scared dang it that was dang that
was not a curse oh boy oh man I've made
it so far I did not think in a million
years I was gonna make it this far
whoa I don't like this ooh oh man I
never ever ever ever thought I was gonna
make it this far because I mean just you
you guys remember what I was like not
thirty minutes ago I was I was a heaving
mess I was distraught thinking that I
had destroyed my channel uh uh you guys
thank you for playing along with me too
the rules make it fun the risk uh-huh
and even though I like to play it safe
the risk cuz I mean I do kind of
understand where mr. Fogg is coming from
I'm never gonna be able to get this
bucket I do understand where it mr.
fatties coming from because I like I
really do like starting over I like
starting over incredibly it's one of my
favorite things to do whenever I play
games like oxygen not included or
factorio which I've been playing in my
spare time like I just oh I love taking
the concepts that I've learned and new
game plussing I love the concept of a
new game plus I'm never never ever
getting this bucket by the way this is
not happening
really Oh got you oh I had that this
bucket is gonna be the death of me
[Music]
ooh
no I just felt the snake looking at me
and I was very scared you know what I'm
not gonna touch this I'm gonna see what
happens
am I just gonna fall off or it yep okay
I fall off eventually if I do nothing
that's a certainty laughs I need just
need to stop hitting it with my head
okay that's that's an option I don't
think it helps me at all nope dingus ah
maximum ooh that's a good one okay so
how do I get like that this oh oh oh wow
oh wow oh wow wowie wowie oh wow Wow
Oh oh my oh my oh my Mamma Mia here I go
again
uh uh-oh that's that's not gonna grab is
it that's that's not gonna stay grabbed
is it okay if I push off straight up
very gently and try to get one of the
hooks above it I think that'll be better
for me okay forward those forward
progress though so you know what the
deal is okay all right I'm never gonna
be able to do that bucket thing again
boy there we go
right here left-right push okay that's
not as bad as I once thought it was hey
I wonder if am I supposed to go top
right because if I am i might just
barely be able to make that worth a shot
I guess cuz I don't think it's gonna end
in my death if I
miss it so let me just angle and launch
ah ah ah okay this is a sheer cliff how
in the world do I do this 100 how how
how how would you be able to is this the
right way do I go the other way what do
I do to the right to the right oh no oh
no no no oh no oh no oh no no I'm scared
how how how do you do how do you do this
[Music]
there's no way there's no way there's no
way there's this little this
legitimately oh how do you even how do
you even could even begin
[Music]
okay all right you can set yourself down
oh that's nestled in there oh that's
nestled okay okay oh oh oh this is so
impossible there's no way ye oh ye oh ye
oh ye oh ye oh ye oh ye oh ye fast oh
you gotta go fast I don't like going
fast I don't like it okay I guess fast
is the way I think not where your hand
moves then I may not follow nor the man
nor the man's hand in this yearís will
his intent the embodied resolved in his
arpel assent
[Music]
oh I'm done I'm done thank you for
protecting in the destroy my channel
challenge I'm done I gotta go I'm so
heartbroken I think I'm about to cry but
thank you I ended on a good note
I made forward progress which you guys
know is Corden's to the deal I I swore a
few times but in the end I made forward
progress so if you believed in me that
means that you subscribed as a reward
and that means the world to me oh oh
that's that hurts so bad but thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye